how's life changed oh yeah because I
what were you a VP or EVP what was that
at least I reported the CEO I was a
senior B's senior vice president but
general manager is the key
hi GM is over there so what's the
difference between you know sitting in
the throne versus you know be on the
right hand of the throne
there's no one there's no one you know
it's like one of the biggest differences
is there's no decision you can't make
and you know when you're when you're
number two at a Cisco or a Microsoft or
you know need these big companies you
don't define the culture I mean you work
for the CEO the CEO defines the culture
that is like make no mistake and if you
if you get that wrong it's like bad
things happen right because you can't
have two people setting culture or three
people setting cultures so that's like
the hugest everything my company now I
said you know the culture comes from me
and you know that so there's no one that
can tell me no which is nice there's you
didn't add enough to check in with
anyone
am i new in my new job you know well
there's downsides of being a much
smaller company but there's also a lot
of upsides to it so there's a mention of
thousand Wow you took over the top slot
and lost 80% of your staff staff yeah
that's much nicer it's I don't let the
work for me
you still can't know everybody but you
can know a lot of people you know a lot
of maybe 300 people 400 people yeah I
have a I have a channel on slack that I
created all thousand people ask me
anything
24/7 I'll answer them instantly I did I
there's literally an ass chasin on
inside slack where I just said listen
just if you've got a question just ask
it f it like work that's like the kind
of a new culture of business which is
like stop looking at the CEO as the god
queen or god king because they're not
yeah you probably know the answer to
your own question exactly probably just
scared I'll let them fire and that's why
you're not just making a goddamn
decision and I encourage people to post
up there and I will answer directly
unpolished it snows no comms people
typing my answer is there's none of that
right just rice book in trouble like
Facebook is so inauthentic that you're
like I mean in the culture the culinary
education okay I haven't seen it it was
very insular like every it's us versus
the world
which was really good like that's an
that's a neat culture - it's a very
effective culture if you want to beat
everybody is to just have that crazy
same as food additive yeah I think how
to circle the wagons mentality at times
it's fierce but then it also leads to a
blind spot which is anytime criticism
comes in you're just like well that's
just people who are trying to take us
down take us down yeah so we should
ignore it and in both companies if you
look at it
ignoring the critics was great for focus
yeah it was really bad for self
correcting unforced errors I guess would
be the way I would tell you yeah you
know it's interesting you said something
I think very profound which just zipped
by and that's one of the reason I love
doing this podcast is I get two times a
week to talk to really really really
smart people who are in the field you
said you can't have more than one
culture and I realized oh there is a
word for having more than one culture
inside a company silos tribalism
tribalism yeah and it's the worst effing
thing you could ever that's why
acquisitions are so hard you're buying a
culture yeah
you can't put you know I've been through
so many of those you you can't change
that you bring it in it is what it is
and that's why so many acquisitions
don't work